MIKE COLEMAN: Hi, I'm Mike
Coleman, a developer advocate
at Google Cloud.
In this video, I want
to introduce you to Kf.
As your teams standardize
on Kubernetes,
migrating applications
from existing platforms,
like Cloud Foundry, is often
one of the biggest challenges.
Kf was designed to help
teams minimize any disruption
to developer workflows during
the migration to Google
Kubernetes Engine and Anthos.
Kf offers developers the
Cloud Foundry experience,
while empowering platform
admins and operators
to adopt declarative
Kubernetes practices.
It makes migrating
Cloud Foundry workloads
to Kubernetes straightforward,
and most importantly,
avoids major changes to
application developer
workflows.
You can also eliminate
commercial Cloud Foundry
licensing costs
and take advantage
of the config and policy
features of Anthos and GKE
for governance.
Before I show you a
demonstration of Kf,
I wanted to talk a bit
about the architecture
and how we map Cloud Foundry
primitives and services
to Kubernetes.
Kf requires Kubernetes and other
open source projects to run.
Some of the dependencies
are satisfied
with Google-managed services.
For example, Google
Kubernetes Engine
provides the Kubernetes backend.
In addition to
Kubernetes, Kf leverages
Tekton to enable Kf build,
which can handle both Buildpack
and Docker file builds.
To take care of setting up
routes for applications,
Kf uses Anthos
Service Mesh, which
is built on Google's
Manage Istio offering.
By default, Kf includes
native integration
with Google Cloud's Cloud
Monitoring and Cloud Logging
services.
This integration lets you
monitor your running clusters,
and help analyze your system
and application performance,
using advanced profiling
and tracing capabilities.
On the monitoring side, Kf has
both an application performance
dashboard, which
provides information
on metrics such as requests
per second, round trip
latency, HTTP error
codes, and more,
as well as a systems
dashboard, which has data
on nodes, pods,
containers, et cetera.
Kf installs several of its own
Kubernetes custom resources
and controllers.
The customer
resources effectively
serve as the Kf API, and
are used by the Kf CLI
to interact with the system.
The controllers use
KFCRDs to orchestrate
the other components
in the system.
You can view these
resources using kubectl.
Before we jump into
our demo, I want
to talk for just a minute
about service brokers.
Service brokers are
software components
that provide an abstraction
of manage service life cycles
across different platforms.
Kf supports service
brokers that are
built according to the open
service broker specifications.
Currently, Kf only supports
credentialed services.
Special services,
such as syslog drains,
volume services, route
services, service keys,
and shared services
aren't yet supported.
In the demo, I'll be
using the Cloud Service
Broker to provision a memory
store for Redis instance.
On that note, let's
jump into the demo,
where I'll show you how
to deploy the spring music
app to Kubernetes using
Kf, as well as how
to provision and manage a
Google Cloud based Redis service
as the backing data store.
As we start our
demo, I've actually
already set up my
cluster-running Kf,
so there are my nodes.
And I've also already configured
the marketplace, or the Cloud
Service Broker.
So we're going to use this Redis
service here later in the demo,
but I just want to
point it out right now.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is create a space
to hold our app.
So I'll create sm-space
for spring music space,
and then we'll go ahead
and target that space.
And now, if we do
a Kf spaces, you
can see the space
we just created,
right there listed sm-space.
The other thing is if
we go in and we kubectl
and we say get spaces,
we can see the name space
for sm-space, so
that's going back
to where Kubernetes
primitives are being
mapped into Kf primitives.
So let's go ahead
and push our app out,
so we'll just do a Kf
push-- we're already
in the directory with the repo.
And that's going to go
ahead and upload the source,
and going to compile it.
It's going to take a little bit,
so I'll fast-forward the video,
and I'll rejoin
you when it's done.
With the application
deployed, let's go ahead
and visit it in the browser.
So clear the screen.
I'll do a Kf apps,
and that will show me
the route to the application.
And I'm just going to go ahead
and grab that URL right here,
and we're going to
copy that, and we're
going to paste it into a
new tab in our browser.
So I'll move up here, create
a new tab, paste that in,
and there's our
application running.
Now what I want to do is I want
to come over here and point out
that we're not using any
profiles or services.
We're going to add
those in the next step.
But I do want to add
a record so I can
have something in the database.
So I had this Paul
McCartney record.
I'll scroll down,
and you can see
that that has been written
to the local data store.
So now what we're going to
do is we're going to go back
and we're going to
connect Redis into this.
So let's move back
into the command line.
I'm going to go ahead
and clear the screen,
and then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to issue the
Create Service command,
and that's going to create that
Cloud Service-backed Google
Redis database in a
high availability mode,
and connect it up
to our application
in the spring music space.
This is going to
take a little bit,
so I'm going to pause the
video, and I'll come back to you
when it's finished.
All right, the service
has been created.
And if you look up
here in the console,
you can see here in Google Cloud
where we actually have created
that memory store with Redis.
So now the next step is
to go ahead and bind that
into our application.
So let's do that right now.
So we'll clear the
screen, and then
we'll do a Kf bind service
here, and what we'll do
is we'll bind the spring
music app to the Redis
database we just created, and
that'll take just a second.
And then when that's done--
which it's done now--
we're going to go
ahead and we're
going to restart
our application.
So we'll do a Kf
restart spring music.
That will allow that new
binding to take effect.
So we give that a second, and
then what we're going to do
is let's head back
into the web browser,
back into our application.
I'll refresh it, and then
we'll move over here,
and you can see now that
we're using the Redis
profile and that database.
And if I scroll down, the record
that I added to the local store
is no longer there, because
we're using the new Cloud-based
Redis data store.
All right, let's move back
into the Cloud Console.
And I want to show you
just a couple more things
before we wrap up.
So the first is
Kf bindings, just
so you can see the
service bindings here,
and we'll list that out, and
you can see that the database is
bound to the application.
So I'll clear the screen again.
The other thing that
I want to show you
is that the vcap-services
are all listed out,
so that standard methodology
for mapping services to apps
is available to
you, and there you
have the JSON for all of that.
There you have it.
That's Kf in a nutshell.
Now, if you need
more information,
check out the links
below, and don't
forget to like and subscribe
so you'll be notified
when we create new content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]